all right great so my name is Clint
Kelly and here tonight to talk to
everybody about key G key G's an open
source platform that lets you more
easily build real time big data
applications on top of Cassandra to get
started the agenda for tonight I'm going
to begin by describing the problem that
we're trying to or the problem that we
set out to solve when we were developing
key G namely building a big data
application I'll talk a little a little
bit about what it means to build such an
application afterwards I'll talk about
how key G works what some of the
components are of this framework and how
it enables you or how it enables all of
us as Cassandra developers to more
easily build these applications then
finally I'll talk about the key G data
model and how we map the key G data
model on top of Cassandra so first a
little motivation for key G let's say
that you're you want to build a
real-time big data application I've
given a few canonical examples of such
applications here to be a little bit
more concrete let's say that you work at
a retailer somewhere like Best Buy and
you want to enhance your website such
that you offer more personalization to
your customers maybe you want to offer
personalized product recommendations for
example so how would we go about
personalizing recommendations well to
begin with we can look at what customers
have added to their shopping carts let's
say that we have a customer Jane and
maybe Jane's just put an iPad in our
shopping cart it makes sense then to
recommend to Jane that she buy maybe an
iPad case or some cables something like
that furthermore if we see that Jane
spends a lot of time on our application
looking
product reviews will probably want a
further part excuse me further
personalize these product
recommendations for Jane by offering her
iPad cases that have five star reviews
likewise we can look at whether she's
applied a lot of filters for the prices
of products what kind of items or what
sort of searches she's performed on our
application and we can also look at how
she or any other customer has interacted
with the mobile version of our
application all of these methods provide
us ways to give our customer a better
personalized excuse-me personalized
experience and tabat provide better
recommendations so that's a quick quick
example a little bit more concrete of
what we mean by one of these
personalized big data applications so
how do we go about building these a good
place to start is with a lot of the
great open source software projects that
are available out there there's a lot of
great stuff it's very scalable and
designed for these kinds of applications
to begin with we need a way to store all
of this data about how customers have
interacted with our application and as
we all know is Kassandra users Cassandra
is a great source or a great option for
storing this kind of this vast amount of
high volume high velocity time series
data once we have all this data in
Cassandra we'll need a way to perform
some computation on it and again a
natural choice for this is Hadoop and
then beyond these there are a number of
other number of other open-source
software projects in this ecosystem that
can be really helpful for us building
this application fortunately we have
companies like data stacks who provide
us with enterprise ready certified
collections of these applications that
we can use or sorry these open source
software projects that we can use to get
started so now it's really up to us to
take all of this open source software
and go from that to this final
real time Big Data application so let's
look at exactly what we need to build to
to build this bridge between those open
source projects in our application to
begin with we need a way to get
information about how our users are
interacting with our our application or
our shopping site into Cassandra we
could design our application such that
we we record user interactions into flat
log files or into relational databases
if we do so we can then use Hadoop to
bulk load all of this data into
Cassandra a more elegant way to design
this application might be to use some
kind of rest interface this would enable
us to store all of the data excuse me to
record all of our user interactions with
our application in real time so
immediately as someone's adding
something to a shopping cart or applying
or performing a search on our website we
can store that data into Cassandra
immediately once we have the data in
Cassandra will likely have some data
scientists on our team and the data
scientists are going to want a way to
query the data we have in Cassandra
using languages that they're familiar
with data scientists are usually quite
comfortable with SQL so we might want to
develop a pipeline that lets our data
scientists use a tool like Apache hive
to read data from our database once
they've gotten data out of Cassandra
with hive they might then want to use
some pretty standard data science tools
like our Python to analyze this data
gain some kind of insights about how
customers use our application and then
apply those insights to develop some
kind of predictive or machine learning
model once we have one of these machine
learning models we need a way to train
it train machine learning model so as
you know everyone who's used these kinds
of model
is familiar typically we want it we want
to train this model over all the data we
have in our database so they'll be
better able to predict how customers are
going to behave it's natural for the
data scientist to wish to train these
models using the familiar tools are in
Python but as I'm sure many of you know
are in Python don't really scale out to
the the vast amounts of customer data
that we can store in a database like
Cassandra a better choice then would be
to do all of our model training using
Hadoop Hadoop is super powerful and very
flexible but unfortunately it's not the
most accessible technology especially
again for for data scientists so we'll
likely want to build we want to provide
some kind of a mechanism for our data
scientists to train the machine learning
model based on all the customer data we
have in Cassandra using some kind of
tool that attempts to kind of bridge
this this gap between the accessibility
of something like R and Python and the
power of doing in OOP analysis so there
are a number of again these open source
projects that attempt to bridge this gap
I listed a couple here scalding spark
and cascading but there are loads of
others as a quick aside when we talk
about a model here we can think of it as
a function the functions input is all of
the information we have about a given
user so this includes all of the
up-to-the-minute time series data we've
recorded about everything a user is
viewed or clicked on or purchased and
the output of this function in this case
is a set of product recommendations for
our customer but it could just as easily
be any other kind of derived insight
about one of our customers it could be
perhaps an estimation over an estimate
of whether if we offer a given customer
free shipping on an item that will lead
to a conversion for example okay and
this model could typically consist
some Java and Scala code but we could
also use some kind of an XML based
representation of a model something like
PMML which use our for example you can
export any trained machine learning
model into PMML in any case once we have
one of these trained machine learning
models we now want a way to apply it in
the case of our example here we want to
apply it to determine the product
recommendations that we wish to provide
later for all of the customers in our
shopping website so one way we could go
about doing this is to use Hadoop we can
pretty easily write a Hadoop job that
will read out of Cassandra all of the
data that we have about all of our users
and then apply our machine learning
model over all the data for all the
users to generate product
recommendations for all of users this
will give us our these derived customer
insights or recommendations for all of
our users in Cassandra but there are a
number of downsides of doing this kind
of a batch operation we'd probably do
this only once a day or maybe once an
hour and so this means that when we
later when our application later wants
to retrieve these generate these product
recommendations for a given customer
they'll likely be a little out of date
because they won't reflect all of the
ways that their customers interacted
with our application since the last time
this patch job was wrong also if we're
we're building something like a shopping
website typically most of our users are
only going to interact with the site
maybe a few times a year or a few times
a month and so if we constantly run
these batch jobs over all of the users
of our application they are wasting a
lot of computational resources - and
I'll describe in a minute how we can
address these problems finally we need a
way to get data out of our database and
back to our application the rest
interface that I described earlier is a
good mechanism for doing so
all right so let's review what we've
described so far and how it works how it
all ties together so let's say that we
have a customer and he's using our
shopping website he clicks on a link
that takes them to a web page that has
some real estate reserved for product
recommendations when he does so our big
data application will talk to Cassandra
over rests and say give me whatever
whatever product recommendations our
machine learning model has generated for
this given user Cassandra will send the
data back over rests and the application
will then render these recommendations
on the screen so this system works but
again we have the shortcomings of a
batch operation leading to a lot of
recommendations that could be out of
date
so how can we do better let's say again
that we have a user interacting with a
with our big data application or
shopping website on his computer it
clicks on a link it takes them to a page
that has some room for recommendations
our application makes a request via rest
to Cassandra
for the for recommendations the show for
this customer now however we add some
application logic around Cassandra this
logic sees this request coming in for a
new cusp for a new recommendation and it
will immediately kick off a real-time
application of our train machine
learning model to generate one of these
recommendations on the fly by doing this
by only executing this machine learning
model now we ensure that the product
recommendations that were writing back
to Cassandra and then serving to our
application are based on the most up to
the second latest information that we
have about how this users been
interacting with our site and also
executing one of these models is pretty
quick and it's easy to do so within the
latency requirements of our application
so after doing so cassandra sends the
recommendations back to the application
and the application renders them on the
screen and the user sees wonderful
product recommendations and oh sorry you
have a question I don't know somebody
else from the team wanna answer that
yeah so the question was were these
latency requirements look like and the
answer is typically on the order of a
100 150 milliseconds yeah so training
the model will take a really really long
time but actually applying it is usually
super quick all right one other thing
that we need to build for this big data
application as we need a way for our
data scientists to run different
experiments our data science team is
probably going to have lots of different
versions of these train machine learning
models I'll have different models for
serving different kinds of
recommendations or other predictions we
want to make about our customers on for
each of these different types they'll
have multiple variants I'll probably
want to run some a/b testing and
determine which ones are the most
effective so we'll need a way to manage
all these different models and we'll
need a pretty elegant way or hopefully a
very elegant way to deploy these models
and bring them bring them on an offline
without having the data scientists
without a lot of latency so in summary
there are three main kind of categories
of functionality that we need to build
first we need a way to get data in and
out of our system on again we doing so
versus rest is probably the most elegant
way to go about this second we need a
way for our data scientists to be able
to inspect the data that we've stored in
Cassandra then they'll need a way to
look at this data gain some insights
then want to develop and train some
predictive or machine learning models
and finally we need a way to apply these
models preferably in real time so that
we can provide recommendations or pour
other insights either door as fresh as
possible and based on this up to the
second time series data we have about
all of our customers so that hopefully
gives you a good overview of some of the
major components that we need to build
to go from all these open source
technologies to our final real-time big
data application and this is a fair
amount of work you can you can build
this but it'll probably take a look take
a fair amount of time and you need a
reasonable size engineering team and
with this in mind we've developed the
qiji project with the idea that it
should help all of us as Cassandra
developers to more easily build these
kinds of applications and really to get
to get a head start and avoid kind of
reinventing the wheel with a lot of this
functionality and instead be able to
focus more on what differentiates our
application and what makes it special
hopefully that gives everyone a pretty
good overview of the problem we're
trying to solve and why we build qiji
now I'll talk a little bit more about
how qiji works and how the different
components of qiji allow us to build
these applications more efficiently
first a little historical note so we
develop qiji a dweeby data we're a
startup company in San Francisco we have
that that's where I work now we have 40
employees qiji was founded in 2010 by
employees from cloud era and Google and
these are folks with a lot of experience
building these kinds of applications I
really enjoy doing this and we're
interested in providing a way to solve
the problems I just described there are
also people with a lot of experience
with open source Big Data technologies
like Hadoop and HBase and finally we've
added since the company was founded
we've added a lot of other folks from
companies like Amazon
LinkedIn that are also in the space in
2010 when we started the company we
originally built qiji on top of HBase in
Hadoop this was a natural choice at the
time cloud era offered excellent
enterprise support for HBase and for
Hadoop and HBase is also integrated very
nicely with Hadoop but since then at
Whidbey data we've seen a remarkable
amount of customer demand for version of
our software and qiji that runs on top
of Cassandra so this year we've added
support we've updated qiji so much that
it's capable of running on top of
Cassandra as well as HBase one other
thing is pretty exciting
we have qiji in production now so as one
fortune 500 retailer I was using qiji
for pretty similar application to what I
just described serving real-time
recommendations to users for products
also Opower
who recently went public uses qiji for
logging time series data about energy
usage and then using it to generate
statistics and reports yes oh so we just
built the Cassandra version this year
I'll talk about the project status a
little bit later but it's not it's not
fully developed yet
so now I'll discuss a little bit about
how qiji works and how the different the
different components of this modular
open-source platform can enable us to
build to more easily build these kinds
of applications on top of Cassandra so
at the heart of key G we have a storage
system and the storage system kind of
sits between the engineers and the data
scientists in your organization for the
data scientists excuse me
engineers typically care about ways to
write data to key G and ways to read it
back and the most important thing to
them is usually having very clean
consistent stable ap is for doing so
where data scientists want a way to be
able to query data from key G query data
from key G and then to analyze this data
and use it to gain some insights then
later develop and train some machine
learning models for the engineers we
provide api's for writing data into key
G this data could come from different
versions of our application running on
various platforms if we design our
applications such that we record user
interactions with it into flat log files
or into relational databases we provide
component key G MapReduce that we can
use to bulk load this data from these
logs and databases into our storage
system as we discussed earlier possibly
a more elegant approach to building such
an application is to use rests so to
this end we provide key G rest key G
rest gives provides a restful api for
writing data again from your application
whether it's on a browser or a mobile or
a browser or an iPhone for example
directly to key G in real time and as we
discussed earlier in addition to
allowing you to write data into key G
this rest interface allows you to
get back as well this storage system
that exists at the center of key G we
call key G schema key G schema provides
a layer of functionality on top of
Cassandra and HBase the data model for
key G schema I will discuss a little bit
more later but it's based on the data
model BigTable so it should be very
familiar to anyone who's used Cassandra
or HBase we can think of it as having
one row for every user of our
application and then within this row we
have a number of columns containing all
the time series data that we've gathered
about how users are interacting with our
application as well as other attributes
about them like names phone numbers
addresses payment information etc the
data scientists as we discussed need a
way to query the data in key G and again
they want to use languages they're
familiar with for this we provide key G
hive which enable excuse me enables data
scientists to use SQL like language to
query all the customer data and key G
schema once the data scientist gets this
data out of key G schema he or she can
analyze it using again data science
friendly tools like our Python then they
can gain some insights about how
customers are interacting with our
application on hopefully apply those
insights to develop some new predictive
or machine learning models that will
improve the customer experience for our
application again the data scientist
could use our Python to then train these
machine learning models but we run into
the problem of those tools not scaling
out to the the massive amount of data we
can store in a database like Cassandra
and certainly your application will be
wildly wildly successful and we won't be
able to handle that much data in our
Python so a data scientist could choose
to use
Hadoop to train this model qiji and key
GM are we have a library of different
predictive and machine learning models
so k-means naivebayes
item item collaborative filtering things
like that but again this requires so so
this is very powerful and it's very
flexible but it requires the data
scientists to be comfortable at Java
which is not usually the case and anyone
who's used to dupe knows it's not the
most user user-friendly tool so we
provide a another component qiji Express
this is one of the one of the coolest
components in qiji this it's based on
scalding which is an open source project
from Twitter and it provides a Scala
based DSL for describing chains of
MapReduce computations this is a very
incise excuse me concise intuitive way
of describing these kinds of
applications you end up with programs
that resemble a series of operations on
the collections library in Scala it's
pretty similar in spirit to spark if
anyone's use that this let's again
provides a way to get a lot of the
accessibility of tools like R in Python
but still leverage the full flexibility
and power of training your models using
a dupe in any case once we have one of
these trained machine learning models we
now need a way to apply it so in key G
we have a notion of a score a score
takes a one of these trained machine
learning models and some information we
have about a customer and produces and
then applies the model over this date
over this customer information to
produce some kind of results again this
in our example this would be a list of
recommended products for a customer but
it could just as easily be be anything
else any other kind of prediction about
the customers behavior for example
if the data scientist wants to apply
these machine learning models in batch
over all of the different users in our
database he can do so using Hadoop in
key GMR but as we discussed this is not
the best approach so instead we provide
mechanisms for implementing that kind of
real-time on-demand evaluation or
scoring of models that we discussed
earlier so let's see how that works
first we have a component called the key
G model repository so data scientists as
they build these new models and put them
into scores can upload scores to the
model repository and make them live once
we have a live score let's say that
again our user is interacting with our
application the application sends a
request via arrests for the latest
product recommendations for a given
customer
this will cause key G scoring to trigger
our score to generate a fresh
recommendation the score will request
from key G schema the latest up-to-date
information we have about a given
customer and after does so it will apply
the machine learning model and then
update and then produce a fresh
recommendation that we can write to the
database after doing so key G schema
will send this data back for your rest
to the application the application can
render can render our recommendations
for our customer so this is really one
of the another one of the the cooler
aspects of key G provides a very elegant
way for doing this kind of real-time
scoring of train machine learning models
and in the model repository we also have
a mechanism for handling all of these
different versions of machine learning
models that we'd want to use for things
like running a be testing different
experiments and so on and this provides
a very very smooth and elegant way for
uploading these models making them live
bringing them offline and managing them
finally we have a notion of a freshness
policy so when we're doing this kind of
real-time scoring with the machine
learning model we might not want to we
might not want to execute it every time
our application asks for some kind of
product recommendation or anything else
about a customer it might be the case if
you know if we're providing these
recommendations based on what's in a
customer shopping cart then we only need
to produce new recommendations every
time a customer the contents of the
customer shopping cart change or we
might just want to represent excuse me
we might only want to produce new
recommendations every hour or every five
minutes and so to this end we provide we
have this notion of freshness policies
they let you indicate how often you want
to execute a score so to recap we talked
about three different bits three
different categories of functionality
that we needed to build for our big data
application we're getting data in and
out of our database in key G we have the
key G rest and key G M are components
for our data scientists to inspect the
data in our database gain some insights
and then develop and train predictive or
machine learning models we have key G
hive key G M R and key G Express and
finally for applying these models doing
so in real time we have the key G model
repository and key G scoring one final
note about this framework it's highly
modular so it might be that for some of
you you're building an application that
looks something like what I've just
described but not exactly so given the
the modular nature of T G you can easily
take whatever components are useful for
you without having to use a big kind of
monolithic project and also if you're
building something it looks like this
but you need some kind of extra
functionality like maybe you want to do
some kind of real-time analysis of these
user events
they occur before they even get written
to your database you could easily write
a component that uses storm or spark
screaming or something like that and
incorporate it okay so hopefully that
gives everybody some idea of the problem
we're trying to solve and then okichi
goes about solving it with this modular
framework now I'll talk about the qiji
data model and how we map that data
model onto Cassandra key G the key G
data model is very similar to BigTable
so again it's going to be really similar
to what you get in Cassandra or an HBase
we store all of our data in tables the
tables consist of rows and rows consists
of some kind of row key as well as data
and key G we call this row key and
entity ID the we support composite
entity IDs and these entity IDs can have
hashed and unhatched components you can
use the hash components to determine how
you spread your data among different
replica nodes in the case of Cassandra
and the unhatched components you can use
to control how data is ordered on disk
for doing scans for anyone is used
Cassandra
this is again really similar to the
notion of partition keys and clustering
or partitioned columns and clustering
columns the data is organized into
different column families within column
families excuse me we have columns sorry
we call these we refer to the column
names as qualifiers again this is same
as BigTable and where are where a data
model diverges so again this so far this
has been pretty similar it's what you
get in Cassandra our data model differs
somewhat from Cassandra you know we have
built-in support for time series data in
Cassandra if you're storing time series
data you'll probably add one clustering
column somewhere in your definition of
your column family
the timestamp in it whereas in qiji we
provide native support for the notion of
timestamp versions of different columns
and again this is this is taken from
from BigTable finally the data we store
in every column consists of complex data
types we use Avro here for serializing
and deserializing the data that we store
in Cassandra Avro is another one of the
open source projects that I referenced
earlier in the talk so these so rather
than just storing like a single string
or a single integer in a column you can
store these complex types that consist
of I can consist of maps and lists and
nested versions of these and enumerated
types finally we have a notion of
locality groups in key G again these are
taken from BigTable and they allow a
user when he specifies the layout of his
table to group together column families
that are accessed together in that we'd
like to have stored on disk together so
let's say for example we're building an
application and we have some set of
column families that we're only going to
access for some kind of batch jobs and
we also have a set of column families
that will access only for some kind of
real time operation that make be
sensible then so we probably want to
store these separately we might want to
have some different attributes for them
whether they're cached for example
whether they're compressed and to do so
we can specify different locality groups
and then put all of our batch column
families at one all of our real time
ones in another and then specify
attributes like that the batch stuff we
might want to keep compressed and on
disk the real time column families we
probably want to keep cached for example
so these locality groups give us a nice
separation between how we want to
organize our data logically in column
families and columns and how we wish to
organize it physically on disk with
locality groups
finally in qiji we have the notion of a
row as the unit of transactional
consistency so we support atomic reads
and comparison sets across rows so now
I'll talk about how we map this data
model onto Cassandra to begin with we
map locality groups to column families
this makes sense I and those of you you
know using Cassandra know that we given
column family we store contiguously on
disk so made me a call or excuse me a
locality group to a column family makes
sense then the entity ID we map to the
primary key of our column family so the
hash components become the partition
columns and the UH gnash components
become clustering columns likewise the
family the qualifier and the version we
also mapped the clustering columns and
finally the data that we store in
Cassandra we store as blobs because
we're using Avro to serialize all the
data that we're storing to give another
look at how this qiji to cassandra
mapping goes this is my artist
interpretation of a single row with a
couple column families in Cassandra so
here we can see the hashed component of
one of our entity IDs we map to the the
row key for our Cassandra row on this
will determine what replica node it goes
on and so on and all of those clustering
columns we described as you know those
of you worked a lot with cql or familiar
those get mapped to composite column
names in Cassandra so again we'll see
everything ordered by first the
unhatched components of our entity ID
and then the column family the column
name in the time stamp and if we had a
couple of different locality groups in
our key G table then here we'd have a
couple of column families in Cassandra
so a few implementation notes on how we
built the Cassandra version of key G we
use the data stacks Java driver so we
did 100% of the implementation with this
we didn't use the thrift API at all we
built it on top of Cassandra 2.6 like
2.7 just came out so probably upgrade
soon we made pretty extensive use of the
async API in the Java driver which was
pretty awesome and I'll describe why we
need that in a minute we also built a
new MapReduce input format that has a
number of features that weren't present
in the in the stock input format that
comes with Cassandra mainly because we
need to support Hadoop 2 but there are a
couple other things we added as well so
now let's talk about some of the issues
with this mapping and how we've
addressed them the biggest issue is that
qiji allows us to allows operations that
operate at the same time on multiple
locality groups so we can have remember
this locality a locality group and qiji
which can contain multiple tables or
multiple column families maps to a
single column family in Cassandra so if
we have a read in key G that goes across
multiple locality groups in the same row
that means we need to have a read in
Cassandra that goes across multiple
column families yes and to implement
this we just have to issue multiple
reads in Cassandra since there's no
mechanism to read from multiple column
families at the same time and this is
one instance of where the async API in
the Java driver really came in handy
because we do a lot of reads real
quickly I get the results back together
this is also one of the reasons that we
had to develop a new Hadoop input format
because we needed to support you know
our MapReduce jobs being able to issue
multiple reads and then combine them in
our record reader another tricky one is
a compare and set that crosses locality
groups so again when you're designing
your qiji table you probably want to put
you're going to put data that's
typically accessed together in a single
locality group so this shouldn't happen
very often but we allow for it in key G
and for this there's really no solution
we can come up with lot since we didn't
want to use zookeeper or something like
that to provide locks on every single
row in our key G table so in the key G
implementation of Cassandra we don't
allow these compare and sets the cross
locality groups and finally in general
we've sacrificed some of this trent some
of this transactional consistency in a
single key G row we still have it for a
single locality group but if you if you
do a read to a row in key G in the
meantime someone could issue a write to
one of those locality groups or someone
could issue a right to multiple locality
groups and your results could be you
could have the old data for one locality
group in the new data for another on so
this is something that we've just chosen
to sacrifice in the notion of better
performance another issue is filters so
HBase provides a very rich set of
user-defined server-side filters the
kind of equivalent in cql is to use
where clauses in your cql queries and
these allow for fairly rich filtering
but it's not quite as powerful as what
we get in HBase so if a user in a qiji
data request chooses the filter based on
some timestamp range or some column
qualifier range those we can translate
to where clauses pretty easily
but if a user has a request in which he
specifies a regular expression on a
column qualifier for example in that
case we just have to do the the
filtering on the client side so you
start looking at some ways to do more of
this filtering on the server in
Cassandra if anyone here has any any
suggestions I'd love to talk to you
after the talk but for now we just issue
some of this filtering on the clients
and really just have to educate our
users about what kind of filters are
very efficient and what art finally
there's an interesting difference in how
we translate these entity IDs with
hashed and unhatched components in the
HBase version of qiji versus the
cassandra version of kiichi so let's say
that we've defined in any excuse me an
entity ID for our application with the
state in the city and the name of our
users maybe we choose to hash the city
and state so we want to distribute our
data among all of our replica nodes
based on the the city and state a users
in and then we leave the username
unhatched so we want to be able to
perform scans over users who are in the
same city in the HBase implementation of
qiji we map this entire entity ID to the
HBase row key we in HBase the row keys
are just byte arrays so we can hash some
components of the any ID leave some of
them on hashed in HBase will order all
this data in lexographic order of the
entity ID in Cassandra on the other hand
we get very wide rows remember we're
mapping these unhatched components of
the entity ID to the clustering columns
in Cassandra so we end up with rows that
are so the rows are dictated by the hash
components which map to our partitioning
columns and then
the rest of the NTID Maps these
clustering columns and this gives us the
functionality that we want because we
can now perform a scan through all of
the different users who live in the same
city and state but it does provide some
limitations that our users need to be
oops
need to be aware of namely that we could
run into limits on the size of one of
these rot wide rows by which I believe
contain two billion elements in them so
this again is not not a big issue but
it's just something that users of the
Kassandra version of qiji need to be
aware of yes alright so the status of
the project we have an alpha version of
key G schema that's available now you
can this URL is a little long so I'll
send this out to the the list or post it
on the website for the meetup but you
can download this now we have a version
of our key G bento box that supports
Cassandra so you can download a tarball
just unpack it run one command and have
a working cluster on your locally on
your machine with Hadoop zookeeper and
Cassandra we have a little tutorial that
lets you build a phonebook that uses a
key a Cassandra key G table so you can
read data to it sorry write data to it
read it back delete entries and so on
over the next quarter
we'll add support for all of the other
components in the key G ecosystem to run
on top of Cassandra the majority of the
work in modifying key G to work on top
of Cassandra was building this Cassandra
version of key G schema in particular
the next quarter we're going to
concentrate on producing a Cassandra
version of key G Express again this is a
really neat tool that lets you very
easily build complicated chains of
MapReduce jobs finally we will begin to
expose some of the Cassandra specific
features to our key G to key G users for
example to allow them when they're
issuing reads or writes to specify
consistency levels
so it's a recap we talked about three
things you need to do to build a big
data application the first was that have
a way to get data in and out of your
database from your application on to
this end we have key G rests and key G
MapReduce the second was to enable your
data scientists to inspect the data and
key G and then use it to gain some
insights and develop and train some
machine learning models for this we have
key G hive key G MapReduce and key G
Express and then finally we need a way
to apply these models in real time to
manage all the models that our data
scientists are building to be able to
deploy them online manage which ones are
active and which ones are not
and for this we have the model
repository and key G scoring so just to
wrap up I want to say thanks to the
Cassandra community for newbies like me
to Cassandra it was really useful to
have all of this information online
everybody who's on the mailing list for
developers and users are really helpful
especially as we were developing this
new loop input format for Cassandra and
also just the amount of videos and
slides and so on that were online from
events like this where made it really
easy to get get up to speed quickly
finally I if you want to get started and
try it now the first URL you can get
access to fully functional bento box and
lots of tutorials and user guides for
all the components I just described and
in the second URL is for the Cassandra
version of the bento box which has
support for schema and a Cassandra
specific tutorial